An orthonormal set is
simply an orthogonal set of unit vectors.
Vectors in orthogonal
sets don't necessarily need to be unit vectors, and in fact you could
even have zero vector
being an element of an orthogonal set, but in an orthonormal set, every vector must be a unit vector
in addition to the
requirement that the set is an orthogonal set.
Given what we know about the relationship between the inner product
and the Euclidean norm, we can express this
condition pretty succinctly
as you see right here.
And finally, an orthonormal basis is simply an orthonormal
set that forms a basis for whatever vector space
we're talking about.
For example, if we take any
classical state set sigma and we think about the set of
all standard basis vectors,
we see that this is an orthonormal set and in fact it's an orthonormal basis for the space of all vectors whose entries correspond to
this classical state set sigma.
These are all unit vectors and
they're orthogonal in pairs, so it's an orthonormal set.
and because it's a basis as well, we have that it's an orthonormal basis.
Orthonormal sets are
always linearly independent by the way, so anytime you
have an orthonormal set, it will always be an orthonormal
basis for some subspace,
but in this case, we have a basis for the entire space that we're working with.
Another example is the set
containing Ket+ and Ket-.
These two vectors are orthogonal, their inner product is equal to zero.
and they're both unit vectors and they span the
two-dimensional space of vector corresponding to a single Qubit, so they form an orthonormal
basis for that space.
Another example is the Bell basis, which is an orthonormal basis for the space of all
four dimensional vectors corresponding to two Qubits.
The set containing Ket 0
and Ket+ on the other hand, is not an orthogonal set because the inner product between
these vectors is non-zero.
They're both unit vectors and this is a basis for the vector space corresponding to a Qubit, but we don't have orthogonality.
Here's a handy fact about orthonormal sets that we'll make use of from time to time.
Suppose that we have some
orthonormal set of vectors, specifically, let's suppose
that we have M vectors in this set, Psi one through Psi M,
where we're assuming that these vectors are drawn from some N
dimensional vector space, or in other words, each of
the vectors has M entries.
As I already mentioned, orthonormal sets are always
linearly independent, so it can't be that M is larger than N,
but it could be that M is smaller than N, and that's the case that
we're interested in.
And what the fact states is
that if M is smaller than N, then it's always possible
to add additional vectors
to the set we started with in order to obtain an
orthonormal basis for our space.
To be precise, there must
necessarily exist vectors Psi M+1 up to Psi N so that the entire collection
forms an orthonormal basis.
So you can never paint yourself
into a corner, so to speak, by somehow choosing an
orthonormal set of vectors that can't be extended to
form an orthonormal basis.
Sometimes you can just look
at the set you start with and figure out how to extend it to form an orthonormal basis, but an alternative that always works
is to use a procedure known as the Gram-Schmidt
orthonormalization process to construct these vectors.
I won't explain that
procedure in this lesson or in this series because the specifics aren't
really important for us, but of course you can look
it up if you're curious.
It's something that can
be performed by a computer in case that's relevant, so
there's no creativity involved, it's just a mechanical procedure.
One of the reasons why this
is such a handy fact to have is concerned with a close connection that exists between orthonormal
bases and unitary matrices.
In particular, for any square matrix U, the three conditions that you see here are always equivalent,
meaning that they're either
all true or they're all false.
The first condition says
that U is a unitary matrix, which means that both U dagger times U and U times U dagger are both
equal to the identity matrix.
The second condition
says that the rows of U form an orthonormal basis
and the third condition says that the columns of U
form an orthonormal basis.
It's actually not too hard
to see why this equivalence is true.
Just to keep things simple, let's take a look at a
three by three matrix U as you see right here, where the entries can be any
complex numbers you like.
Here on the left hand side I've written U conjugate transposed
just for convenience.
If we form three vectors
from the columns of U, which here are named Psi
one, Psi two and Psi three, then if we take the
product of U dagger and U,
you can check that each
entry of the product is given by an inner product of vectors as we see right here in this pattern.
And now when you think about the condition that U is unitary, which is equivalent to this matrix being equal to the identity matrix,
you see that it's equivalent
to the three vectors forming an orthonormal set.
The diagonal entries all
have to be equal to one, so these are necessarily unit vectors, and the off diagonal
entries have to be zero,
so it's an orthogonal set of vectors.